the leftist culture war against
traditional masculinity continues to
gain steam as china takes a different
path and nbc news recommends you skip
the turkey this thanksgiving i'm ben
shapiro this is the bench bureau
[Music]
show this show is sponsored by
expressvpn don't like big tech and the
government spying on you visit
expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment first let me just ask a quick
question when did we decide to stop
upholding free speech as a basic right
which is pretty obvious i mean this is
obvious that the big tech companies this
is no longer a main priority which means
they're handing over your data to people
who shouldn't have your data they're
basically acting like a window not a
wall for your private information you
need to protect yourself in the way the
big tech companies simply will not and
that is why i use expressvpn have you
ever wondered how free to access tech
giants make all their cash well the
answer is they track your searches your
video history and everything you click
on by building a profile on you and then
selling off your sensitive data they
make all that money when you use the
expressvpn app on your computer or phone
you anonymize much of your online
presence by hiding your ip address that
makes your activity more difficult to
trace and sell to advertisers what's
more expressvpn encrypts 100 of your
network data to protect you from
eavesdroppers and cybercriminals what i
like most is how easy it is to use it
takes just one click to protect all your
devices which is why expressvpn is rated
number one by business insider so stop
letting big tech grab all your data
instead secure your internet with the
vpn i trust for online protection visit
expressvpn.com
that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s
vpn.com to get three extra months free
with my exclusive link go to
expressvpn.com
ben right now to learn more okay so
very often on this show we spend a lot
of time on sort of the day-to-day
political
insanity that is breaking out across the
nation but there are underlying trends
in american politics that are really
disturbing for the future of the country
and maybe the most disturbing underlying
trend in america right now is the
substitution of radical subjectivity for
basic objective truth what i mean by
that is people tend to think that their
truth matters more than
the truth my truth matters more than the
truth and once you make that stark
division basically your society is at an
end because reality has certain dictates
reality requires that you live within
its boundaries reality means that you
have to understand how the world works
how nature works and then you have to
adapt yourself to those realities
instead as a society we have decided to
use every means at our disposal in order
to reshape the reality around us or at
least what reality can do to us in order
to prevent that reality from intruding
so when it comes to
everyday life we have set up systems
whereby no one is allowed to criticize
us if we are if we are criticized we get
very very upset and then we try to rig
the system so no one can ever criticize
us again if fat patterns emerge they
threaten our view of the world we simply
use the the bottlenecking
technologies at our disposal to prevent
that sort of feedback loop from harming
our interests and our narrative so if if
a case if a criminal case goes the way
we don't want it to go we simply have
people on the tv repeat back to us what
we want to hear as opposed to the
reality of the situation
when it comes to how we wish to live our
lives how we feel on the inside this is
supposed to matter an awful lot more how
reality matters and we are now using
technology as sort of the all-purpose
wonder drug so we're creating entire
artificial realities where we can live
completely free of reality itself
and there is a philosopher named robert
nazak robert nazix a libertarian
philosopher and he once posited what he
called the experience machine he said
that most human beings are interested in
freedom in the real world he said if you
could be plugged into a machine
where you spent all day experiencing the
feeling that what you were doing was
real but where all of your activities
simply resulted in success would you do
it
and he posited no because most people
still want to live in the real world
most people want to feel like their
their work has real impact on other
people
i'm not so sure anymore i think that we
have now created if if
karl marx suggested that that religion
was the opiate of the masses i think
that we have created
actual opiates in the form of of online
addiction in the form of virtual
realities in the form of a media created
reality and we feed ourselves this drug
that separates us off from the reality
and and we just have people reflect back
at us what we want to hear i think a lot
of people would plug into that
experience machine now that robert nas
experience machine they would give up
their ability to affect real change in
the real world in favor of a sort of
solipsistic
drug-induced soma virtual soma from
brave new world and that's really
disturbing
and and i think that we have entire
institutions that are built up around
this we have institutions that cater to
our every whim we have algorithms that
tell us the stuff that we need and at no
point are we ever confronted with the
realities of the actual real world and
when we are we get insulted by those
realities we get angry with those
realities there's only one problem with
this and that is reality wins anyway we
can fight reality we can construct
artificial realities we can create
worlds in our own imagination and we can
occupy those worlds with others who also
wish to live in their own imagination we
can all live inside facebook's meta
but that is not going to change the
reality that for billions of people
around the world most people throughout
human history and most people right now
those virtual realities not only don't
exist they are seen as spiritually
innervating as spiritually emptying as
counterproductive
civilizations that drug themselves into
innervation lose and that is what we are
watching right now
according to the washington post more
u.s adults who do not already have kids
say they are unlikely to ever have them
this is according to a new pew research
study survey findings that could draw
renewed attention to the risks of
declining birth rates for industrialized
nations there's not a single
industrialized nation in the west i
think the only exceptions are georgia
and israel that has a replacement level
birth rate meaning at least two kids in
order for your population to maintain
every two parent household has to have
two kids okay but in the united states
that number is more like one seven in
italy that number's like one two that
means these populations are going to be
dropping dramatically
according to the washington post experts
are concerned that the u.s birth rate
which has declined for the sixth
straight year may not fuel enough
population growth on its own to keep the
future economy afloat and to fund social
programs women between the ages of 18 to
49 and men between 18 and 59 who said
they are not parents were asked the
question thinking about the future how
likely is it that you will have children
someday in october 26 of them said it is
very likely a six point drop from 2018
when 32 percent answered very likely
meanwhile the share of americans who
answered not too likely in 2021 grew to
21 compared to 16 in 2018. so we now
have near parity
between the number of americans who say
that it is very likely that they will
have kids and not too likely that they
will have kids when asked why they don't
want to have kids 56 percent of
childless adults who say who said it is
not at all or not too likely they will
ever have kids said it's because they
just don't want them
that's a change from 2018 when 63
percent of childless adults in those
categories said it was because they had
no desire for children
this time around 43 cited other reasons
including medical issues economic or
financial reasons lack of partner
the bottom line is that this is part of
a broad scale trend in the west people
just don't want kids and the reason
people don't want kids is because they
don't live in the real world
they live in a world in which the
government takes care of all their
future problems all of the incentives
why you used to have kids are basically
gone in the west
so the reasons you used to have kids for
example were you needed child labor to
work your farm okay thank god that is no
longer an issue then it was well you
want the spiritual connection that you
get from your kids and then we decided
to kill spirituality
and then the idea was you had a moral
obligation to have kids and then we said
no no you have a moral obligation not to
have kids because your kids are going to
ruin the earth and then we said well you
know at the very least we need to have
kids because who's going to pay for us
in our old age and the idea is well the
government will pay for us in our old
age the government has endless reams of
cash so it doesn't matter
so what is the incentive structure
outside of the religious communities to
have kids and the answer is there is
none which means the only people who are
going to be having kids are the people
who are not engaged in this sort of
solipsistic
self-obsessed naval gazing
you know where do i vacation with my
small dog this week the only people who
are going to be having kids in the
united states and in the west generally
are religious people and this is what
the stats show every religious community
in the united states is reproducing at
above replacement rates every secular
atheistic agnostic community is
replacing is having kids at below
replacement rates
so if you're a fan of secular liberalism
i got to ask you what do you think your
future is
really how do you think that that's
going to reflect may could it be that
the secular liberalism disconnected from
the root values that created the space
for liberalism to arise in the first
place has been self-defeating is it
possible that when you cut off the roots
of the tree the tree just dies when you
get rid of the moral precepts that
allowed for a sphere of freedom to
emerge in the west
that the freedom itself kills the tree
is that possible because that seems to
be what we're watching in real time
that freedom
unbound from morality unbound from
reality because morality and reality are
related in this sort of teleological old
philosophical sense if you get rid of
that if you say that there's just fact
patterns and freedom all you end up with
is libertarianism and that's where we
are in a society i define myself how i
want you have to you have to confirm how
i define myself if reality hits me in
the face that's not reality hitting me
in the face we have to construct systems
to insulate me from reality so i don't
have to make good decisions anymore i
don't have to make the decisions that
lead to success i don't have to make the
decisions that lead to a future for my
country or for my family
in april the census bureau reported that
in the last decade the us population
grew at the second slowest rate for any
10-year period since the nation's
founding
pew surveyed 3 800 parents and
non-parents online in late october as
part of a broader study of nearly 10 000
us adults known as the american trends
panel survey those who said they have no
kids were asked to rate their desire to
have them in the future adults who said
they already have kids were asked to
rate their likelihood of having more
there is no difference based on gender
in the responses among parents and
non-parents according to pew men and
women are equally likely to say they
will probably not have kids or more kids
in the future
there was a difference based on age
adults in their 40s were far more likely
than younger adults to say they are
unlikely to have any or more kids in the
future which of course makes sense the
older you get the harder it is to have
kids what's striking there is the lack
of difference between men and women in
their view of having kids
typically speaking you would imagine
that women would be more interested in
having kids than men
just because historically speaking this
has been the case
and by the way when it comes to poll
data i'm still not sure that that is
reflective of how normal people act what
i mean by that is there a lot of people
who say they don't want to have kids and
then women have kids and then they want
to take time out from the workforce to
spend with their kids how people act is
very different than what they are asked
in polls however what the demographic
rates show is that we are a society in
decline
in massive decline
and we are also a society that is in
decline because we have decided to make
our people genderless widgets men and
women are exactly the same in fact they
are so the same that men can become
women and women can become men gender
makes no difference at all sex makes no
difference at all and to point out that
sex makes a rather large difference in
how the world works is to be labeled
some sort of bigot
even though the fundamental basis of a
of a civilization that is growing is a
recognition of the difference between
men and women because literally all
human growth all human reproductive
capacity is based on sexual dichotomy
between men and women and recognizing
that the differences between men and
women are not only important but very
beautiful and very wonderful but we're a
society that has decided that the apex
of being a man is not to be a protector
and guardian and provider for your
family
it is to basically sit home play video
games and tweet out the latest hashtag
and the apotheosis of femininity is not
to have kids and to raise them in
conjunction with your husband instead
the apotheosis is to work 2200 billable
hours as a paralegal at the local law
firm
i'm sorry that is not a civilization
that has a future
it is not that is not to say that women
can't do those things and have kids they
can my mom worked my dad stayed home
my wife is a doctor
okay it is to say that the fundamental
root of civilization has to recognize
the massive and important differences
between men and women or men will not be
men and civilization will fall and women
will not be women and people will not
reproduce
and that is what we are seeing right now
and the media are pushing this okay
let's just face this serious fact i know
that we're not supposed to talk about
these things there are major differences
between men and women these differences
range from the biological everything
from height to to
muscle capacity
to to how the brain works these are very
different between men and women and they
were meant to be this is a good thing
it's not just true for humans for all
mammals all mammals are rooted in sexual
dichotomy to pretend that that doesn't
exist and and to as a culture attempt to
fight that is an attempt to fight
reality reality is going to win
when i say reality is going to win i
mean there are other civilizations that
are not delusional the way the united
states is delusional the way the western
civilization has decided to buy into the
mass delusion of a sort of cartesian
duality between the genderless spirit
and the sexed body
okay that is not reality that is not how
the world works you are an integrated
being
your spirit and your body are one okay
they they work together
this belief that you are sort of a
floating ghost in the machine
has not been true forever and it wasn't
true when they wrote about it
but we have we have convinced ourselves
of this
fantasmic
chimera and uh and it is not going to
end well for us in a second we'll get to
some of the differences between men and
women that are quite important and then
we'll talk about why it is that we are
as a society failing first let's talk
about the underwear that grace or took
us right now so my magnificent took his
grace right now by tommy john underwear
when you start your day wearing tommy
john you're that much more comfortable
so you can do everything better
shop their black friday sale right now
give the gift of comfort to everyone on
your list including yourself with tommy
john men and women's loungewear with
over 16 million pairs sold giving the
gift of tommy john underwear and
loungewear has become a holiday
tradition for families all across the
country 98 of women and men love getting
a gift from tommy john which is why
tommy john doesn't have customers they
have fanatics honest to goodness when i
got tommy tron underwear all of my other
underwear went in the garbage they they
were not durable they were not
comfortable tommy shawn's
they are great they last basically
forever this holiday make everyone in
your family that much more comfortable
with the gift of tommy john loungewear
underwear and bras plus it is all backed
by tommy john's best pair you'll ever
wear or it's free guarantee during tommy
john's black friday sale get 20 off site
wide at tommyjohn.com ben get 20 off for
a limited time only at tommyjohn.com
ben go right now to tommyjohn.com ben
see site for details okay so there are
these vast differences between men and
women these are very durable we've known
about them forever
a good paper by jana
weisberg from the department of
psychology in linfield college and colin
de young university of minnesota
department of psychology jacob hirsch
university of toronto this is from a few
years back 2011 from frontline
psychology talking about the differences
between men and women
there there are these personality traits
called the big five personality traits
and these are very durable psychological
findings they're major differences
between men and women and many of the
personality traits that are expected to
to be present in human beings so for
example neuroticism neuroticism
describes the tendency to experience
negative emotion and related processes
in response to perceived threat and
punishment these include anxiety
depression anger self-consciousness and
emotional ability women generally score
higher than men on neuroticism as
measured at the big five trait level
additionally women also score higher
than men on related measures not
specifically designed to measure the big
five like indices of anxiety and low
self-esteem
men tend to get more angry and so women
tend to be more neurotic in the big five
and men tend to get more angry within
this category which makes sense men are
more aggressive women tend to worry more
about the details again this is not true
for every woman or every man we are
talking about on average these on
average differences make a very large
difference in how we as a society treat
maleness and femaleness
when it comes to agreeableness
women consistently score higher than men
on agreement agreeableness and related
measures such as tender mindedness which
of course makes sense this would be
altruism empathy kindness by the way you
can see this in job selection women tend
to select jobs where they have
interpersonal contact reliant on empathy
men tend to like machines
there's a reason for this because
biologically speaking women tend to be
maternal in instinct and men tend to be
protective or or aggressive and instinct
when it comes to conscientiousness
there's no market difference between men
and women or at least not a durable one
across cultures when it comes to
extroversion assertiveness sociability
positive emotionality
gender differences are small on the
overall domain level of extraversion
women typically score a little bit
higher but that's because women score
higher on warmth gregarious
gregariousness and positive emotions men
score higher on assertiveness and
excitement seeking right men are more
risk-taking this has been proved by
pretty much every psychological study
men again tend to be more aggressive
and when it comes to openness and
intellect which reflects imagination
creativity intellectual curiosity and
appreciation of aesthetic experiences
there are no significant gender
differences typically found on openness
or intellect
women
typically score higher on aesthetics and
feelings men tend to score higher on the
ideas facet again a lot of this seems
stereotypical but it is also rooted in a
biological difference between genders
okay why is all of this important the
reason that all of this is important is
because when we as a society sublimate
reality in favor of a peculiar vision
that all men and all women are
genderless what we end up with is a
society that does not reproduce that
does not see responsibility in a serious
way we are we are not paving the way for
true human flourishing there's a lot of
talk in philosophy philosophy about
human flourishing what that constitutes
what does it mean to flourish as a human
being so from the marxist perspective
human flourishing basically the
predicate to it is material well-being
now you have to make sure that you have
enough stuff let's make sure that you're
taken care of and then we will all
flourish is the the notion that that a
marxist society will will breed a
society of artists and and innovators
this is what nancy pelosi says when it
comes to job lock right get rid of job
lock create a better welfare state and
society will flourish forth then there's
a vision of human flourishing
that suggests that human flourishing is
about the cultivation of particular
individual goods meaning you cultivate
friendship or you cultivate virtue right
that's sort of a more anxious idea
i think and when it comes to human
flourishing i think this is the
judeo-christian worldview as well i also
think that it tends to be backed by
evolutionary biology human beings are
essentially tools we are the swiss army
knife of the creatures this is something
that bretton heather weinstein brett
breinstein and heather hein talk about
in in their book
on evolutionary biology both of them are
evolutionary biologists the basic idea
is that human beings are really good at
adaptation that's what we are good for
and what that means is that because we
are a swiss army knife we fulfill
particular roles some of those roles
include learners
creative forces in the world right we as
human beings have an instinct to create
protectors which typically tends to fall
more on men
guardians and and and parents
maternal influences tends to fall more
on women
and there are sex roles there are some
that are less sex and then there are
some that are more sexed
to ignore gender differences in roles is
to as a society defeat yourself to
pretend for example that men and women
are have an equal duty to serve in armed
forces
cuts against virtually all of human
history and also basic biology not to
suggest that female soldiers can't do an
amazing job
many of them do
but if you are on a battlefield and
you're about to fight a battle what you
would like is an army of
if you have to pick between an army
entirely abandoned an army entirely of
women you're going to pick an army
entirely of men they have greater
physical capacity they tend to follow
orders a little bit better according to
sociological studies uh and they tend to
be more aggressive
again that's not to demean women in any
way there are things that women are much
better at than men
but all of society rests on these
foundational principles
and failing to recognize the true beauty
and difference between men and women
leads to a society where men are told
that they don't need to be men which by
the way makes room for actual toxic
masculinity and women are told that they
shouldn't be women in any way which
leads to
a sort of
genderless
apathy about the future of the human
race this is a problem when women don't
want to have kids and when men don't
want to defend their families or feel an
obligation to do so societies end
and other societies that actually
recognize realities don't end they just
continue on they reproduce they have
kids they they bring up those kids in
healthier ways
and why i say health i don't mean ways
that we would approve of i mean ways
that propagate their societies their
civilizations
healthier on almost an objective metric
level
and when that happens
societies begin to crumble that's what
we're watching here in the west
i bring this up because there's an
article in politico today that's quite
fascinating
all about why republicans can't stop
talking about masculinity and the answer
is maybe when you tell men young men
particularly they have no role in our
society
when you tell a society that risk taking
is bad aggressiveness is bad the
meritocracy is bad you end up
undermining the society and when you
tell women
that women ought not have kids that
abortion is the highest good you end up
with a society that is completely crazy
a society removed from reality well
here's the thing reality doesn't care
reality is going to come for all of us
we'll get some more of this in just one
second first let's talk
about your sleep quality so
you're about to pass into that food coma
right thanksgiving is coming i know what
you're going to do you're going to grab
that turkey and grab those mashed
potatoes the cranberry sauce the whole
deal i'm gonna go for the stuffing and
then you're gonna wanna conk out well
when you fall asleep make sure that
you're relying on the heavenly
luxuriousness of a helix sleep mattress
helix sleep has a quiz it takes just two
minutes to complete it matches your body
type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you why would you
buy a mattress made for someone else
with helix you're getting a mattress you
know will be perfect for the way you
sleep everybody is unique helix knows
that so they have different mattress
models to choose from they have soft
medium and firm mattresses mattresses
great for cooling you down if you sleep
hot mattress is great for spinal
alignment to prevent morning aches and
pains even a helix plus mattress for
plus size sleepers
so if you're looking for a mattress you
take the quiz you order the mattress you
match to the mattress comes right to
your door ship for free you don't ever
need to go to a mattress store again
you've got a 10-year warranty you have
to try it out for a hundred nights risk
free they'll even pick it up for you if
you don't love it but you will helix
even has financing options and flexible
payment plans so a great night's sleep
is never far away i took that helix quiz
my wife and i have a firm mattress very
breathable it is super comfortable just
go to helixsleep.com
take their two minutes leave quiz they
will match you to a customized mattress
that will give you the best sleep of
your life helix is offering up to 200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners at
helixsleep.com
ben okay so if my theory and i think the
theory of evolutionary biology is
correct that human flourishing rests in
fulfillment of particular roles that
human beings are good at fulfilling and
that are durable across cultures roles
like father roles like protector roles
like mother roles like empathizer roles
like community member right if if you
are designed to fill a bunch of roles
over the course of your life
right and you like many roles you're not
one role you're not just a dad you're
not just a brother right you're not just
a protector you're not just a creative
horse you're all of these things you're
not just a mom you're not just a sister
you're not just somebody who's involved
in your community you're all of these
things if we as a society boil ourselves
our identities down to one thing we
flatten out human existence and human
flourishing becomes impossible so if we
boil ourselves down to for example just
creators of economic product that is one
aspect of human flourishing it is not
the only aspect of human flourishing and
if that comes at the expense of us
making the decisions that allow us to
flourish in all these other ways society
falls apart you can have really high gdp
and also a crumbling society
similarly if we flatten ourselves out to
only our sexual instinct which used to
be sublimated to role fulfillment right
the sexual instinct used to be
sublimated to a broader role it wasn't
just you had a sexual instinct it was
that sexual instinct was supposed to
come in the context of a marriage that
produced children and a healthy
upbringing
and provided the impetus for you to
become a protector for your family and
to become become maternal influence if
you're a mom
these things were very important when
you separate that off and you basically
say your genitals are you
right or your genital pleasure is you
if you say that you have flattened out
humanity to its thinnest veneer
and as a society human flourishing
becomes nearly impossible
this is why masculinity and femininity
matters this is why it matters when you
are told the lie and when your kids are
indoctrinated in the lie that gender is
entirely malleable and that it's not
important and that if you mention that
it's important it's really bad
okay so there's an article in politico
today
trying to take this on okay it's an
article a q a with historian kristen
kobes dumez on josh haley jd vance why
manhood seems to be such a big topic on
the right today the answer is of course
because you have millions of
dispossessed young men who have been
told they have no role in society
you want a healthy society you want
healthy young men give them
responsibility give them duty tell them
they have a role in the world
as a society we've told them they don't
have a role in the world
in fact we've told women that their
roles and male roles are exactly the
same
and we have told men that if they insist
on on roles as father and protective and
protect her this is somehow degrading to
women which of course is idiotic idiotic
okay according to politico republican
lawmakers and hopefuls seem particularly
interested in the idea of masculinity
lately in a tv interview earlier this
month missouri senator josh halley
claimed the left was telling them their
masculinity is inherently problematic
that's true he also told interviewer
mike allen who would make masculinity a
signature political issue why because
the pre-political basis of all human
society is the family you know it's
really important family in in families
masculinity a dad who's a provider and a
protector that is very very important it
is true in all human societies which i
am aware
hallie's comments sounded similar to
those of representative madison
clawthorn of north carolina went viral
last month in a video calling on mothers
to raise their sons to be monsters what
he meant by that of course was the sort
of jordan peterson notion that men are
monsters and you have to use that
aggression in positive ways not that
women should should raise men or
in order to be aggressively evil but
that men are aggressive that aggression
can be channeled in defense itself and
others or it can be channeled in
horrifying directions which is what
you've largely seen in american society
men channeling their aggression toward
violence or channeling their aggression
toward drug use or channeling or just
being innovated completely because their
mission has been taken away from them
vance tweeted that the the written house
trial filled him with indescribable rage
said we leave our boys without fathers
we let the wolves that set fire to their
communities and when human nature tells
them to go and defend what no one else
is defending we bring the full weight of
the state and the global monopolist
against them okay so here's politico's
objection according to historian kristin
kobas dumez this way of talking about
masculinity has its roots in
conservative evangelical spaces but it's
going mainstream jemez wrote a book last
year called jesus and john wayne how
white evangelicals corrupted a faith and
fractured a nation about how the model
of masculinity and evangelicalism went
from emulating the qualities of jesus to
emulating those of the actor john wayne
and how that has shaped culture and
politics ever since well who's to say
that the values of jesus and the values
of john wayne are in direct conflict
why the whole idea of john wayne as a
character is that he was an honorable
man who was out defending hearth home
and society
it's sometimes on the edge of the law in
order to do so
zuma says within conservative
evangelical spaces first of all there's
the idea that masculinity is a god-given
thing okay that's not just the idea of
of conservative evangelicals by the way
that masculinity is a god-given thing
it's a biology given thing i'm sorry to
break it to secular liberals but
masculinity is baked into the cake
and that is that is not just a question
of of god making it that way although as
a religious person i believe he did i
believe male and female he created them
but i think that's a reflection of basic
human biology and by the way all
mammalian biology
but says christian kobe's dimes when
holly is talking about an attack on men
and saying the left is attacking manhood
and they hate this country and don't
believe in gender all of that sounds
very familiar in white evangelicalism
this has been a refrain for decades now
by the way try again this has not been
refrained for decades now this has been
a refrain since the bible
the bible has explicit bands i mean i'm
rather familiar with the first five
books the bible has explicit bans on men
dressing as women and women dressing as
men for example
says this uh says this quote unquote
scholar in evangelical spaces christian
manhood has long been equated
particularly in conservative circles
with a kind of rugged militant quality
it's not just about rugged and militant
that's not what it's about it's about
what is your role what roles are you
fulfilling when you remove roles from
men and tell them the rules are bad when
you say marriage is bad and fatherhood
is bad you don't need a dad and you
don't need and you don't need protectors
and you don't need soldiers are bad cops
when you say this sort of stuff you
remove all place for male aggression to
go by the way male aggression is going
to go exactly those places in other
societies it just ain't going to go
there here
you can remove the masculinity from the
west but you can't remove the
masculinity from the world
and if you remove the masculinity from
the west the west will crumble there are
other forces out there that do not give
a bleep they don't care
but says this scholar this is a kind of
reactionary masculinity that emerges in
the 1960s and 70s in conservative
evangelical spaces and more broadly in
american conservatism
the context here is important coming out
of the post-war era there was a baby
boom traditional family values were all
the rage at least among the white middle
class well no they were all the rage
among everybody
during the baby boom the black single
motherhood rate was below 20
today it's about 70 percent then you
have this disruptive moment in the 1960s
says this writer you have the civil
rights movement which is particularly
disruptive in the american south to the
status quo of the early feminist wave
and second wave feminism of the 60s and
very importantly the vietnam war and the
anti-war movement all of these are seen
to destabilize the social order
conservatives are particularly concerned
in all three of these cases it's the
assertion of white patriarchal authority
or power that can restore order and to
understand the revolutionary forces that
want to tear down gender what she's
saying the implicit understanding of
what she's saying the revolution the
revolutionary forces that wish to
destroy the the institutions of the
united states
are focused on tearing down masculinity
as a pathway to doing so
that is part and parcel of this because
if you have men who are willing to
defend those institutions
then the institutions won't fall
they they so she says that the assertion
of traditional masculinity would have
been against for example the civil
rights movement that's weird because it
seems to me that there are plenty of
good powerful strong men who are
standing up in favor of the civil rights
movement i was unaware that it was
enervated hippies who were leading the
civil rights movement as opposed to
strong powerful men and strong powerful
women all of whom were gendered at the
time because we're talking about the 60s
not the 1990s and not the 2010s
we're leading that movement the inherent
feminization of powerful civil rights
movement is pretty astonishing i mean i
i think you'd be very hard pressed to
make the case that either martin luther
king jr or malcolm x were effeminate men
that's a very difficult case to make
but says dumas i think that this
language is becoming more useful in the
wake of the trump years there's a lot of
history particularly of republicans
unfavorably comparing democratic men and
masculinity against a stronger more
rugged american manhood it kind of had a
resurgence during the obama presidency
it was very popular for republicans to
impugn his masculinity and to question
his manhood and his strength okay well
i never questioned barack obama's
manhood he's a father with kids which to
me is is the mark of a true man
i questioned his his assertiveness in
foreign policy i questioned his policy
priorities which seemed to me not to
foment the kind of aggressiveness and
masculinity and risk-taking that you
need as natural society which brings us
to where we are in terms of policy today
because it's not just a question of of
degrading men to the level of the
genderless it's also a question of as a
society do you get rid of masculine
values like risk taking risk taking
tends to be a more masculine value
do you get rid of those values in favor
of a of a broader value of empathy as a
society and if you do what does that do
to society
and the answer is it destroys your
society
because when you get rid of the risk
taking when you get rid of the
innovation when you get rid of the harsh
realities they both provide the
incentive for risk taking but also
punish stupid risk taking
then you end up with a society that is
completely stagnant
which is why for example the university
of california is now deciding that in
favor of empathy they're going to get
rid of standards and innovation and risk
taking and reality reality must be
shielded you have to shield yourself
from reality so for the foreseeable
future there's no standardized testing
for the university of california why
because minorities weren't getting in at
the rates that the uc wanted them to get
in so they just got rid of the
standardized test
which by the way is kind of racist
because the idea is that black people
apparently can't do well enough on tests
in order to be admitted so you have to
set up a different metric where they
will do well
which seems
rather both paternalistic and sneering
at black americans is not true by the
way black americans are fully capable of
doing well on tests but
the notion is that if we get rid of the
metric then everything is it gets all
better get rid of the standards get rid
of the requirements get rid of the
metrics
get rid of the of the requirement that
you work hard and that you take the risk
and society somehow improves that's a
lie we'll get to that in a second as i
say there are other societies that are
waiting with baited breath for us to do
exactly this sort of stuff first
there's still time to make a positive
impact on your budget before your end
mortgage rates remain near money-saving
lows now you might be thinking why my
mortgage is fine as is well what you
should be asking is how can my mortgage
work for me that answer can be found in
american financing america's home for
home loans
they will give you sound advice they're
not going to pressure you they're not
going to give you a hard sell instead
their salary salary-based mortgage
consultants get to know you so they can
lead you to greater overall savings it
could be as simple as finding a shorter
loan term or consolidating debt
there's more to refinance than just a
lower rate and through this they save
customers up to a thousand dollars a
month it's a lot of money so why not see
what they can do for you make the ten
minute call right now before the rates
are gone eight six six seven two one
thirty three hundred that is eight six
six seven two one thirty three hundred
or visit americanfinancing.net nmls 182
334 and mls consumeraccess.org
again i think the mortgage rates are
going to go up sometime in the near
future because the fed is beginning to
taper i think they're going to have to
make debt more expensive this means
mortgage rates will rise now is a great
time to refi before that happens head on
over to americanfinancing.net or give
them a call at 866 721
3300 okay so as a society if we embrace
empathy to the exclusion of
aggressiveness and merit and risk taking
and standards we will die
a society needs both empathy and
aggressiveness it needs male and female
these are characteristics that by the
way again have been seen in every
society since the beginning of time and
this is not to deny that there are women
who can be more masculine and men who
can be more effeminate it is to say that
on average there are differences in
quality between male and female as
everyone understands and that these
qualities are very important in the
society and should be pressed forward
fomented and fostered by a society that
remains healthy
okay so what ex so in other countries by
the way they're not doing this in other
countries
you know opposing civilizations they're
not playing games with any of this stuff
and they've decided that they are going
to prevent people from from
living in a sort of mesmatic genderless
space where all of their desires are
reflected back at them there's a good
piece by a person named habi zhang in
the wall street journal today a doctoral
student in political science talking
about the coddling of american children
quote as a chinese doctoral student
raising a young son in the united states
i'm mystified by how american elementary
schools coddle students in china schools
are run like boot camps what do the
therapeutic comforts america showers on
its youth pretend for a growing
competition with china i recently
registered my son in the third grade at
new jersey public school hattie had
recently finished two years of
elementary school in chengdu china where
he tried it off to school each day with
a backpack stuffed with thick textbooks
and materials for practices and quizzes
here he leaves for school with little in
his backpack other than a required
healthy snack the first day he came home
with a sheet of math homework 35 edition
problems he finished in about a minute
on the second day he was asked to write
328 in different configurations he first
wrote down 300 plus 20 plus 8 following
the prompt and then 164 times 2 82 times
4 and 656 divided by 2.
my son is not a genius but he started
studying math at an early age it is a
core belief in chinese society that
talent can be trained so schools should
be tough on children chinese students
score at the top of international math
and science tests we've got the ucs
removing the sats and acts because god
forbid too many asian students get in
and at the same time you got chinese
schools that are basically saying no no
you guys are going to be forced to to
learn you're going to be provided the
opportunity to learn you're going to be
expected to learn
this is not a philosophy shared by
american schools says this writer on
friday night my son came home announcing
in bewilderment he didn't have any
homework in china students tend to
receive twice as much homework on the
weekend given the two days to complete
it how will america compete with china
determined to train the best
mathematicians scientists and engineers
unfolding now are two maoist cultural
revolutions one in the east and the
other in the west the former is a
jingoistic nationalism enforced by party
loyalties and ubiquitous secret secret
police the latter is an anti-americanism
enforced by progressive mobs seeking to
defund the police both are about
limiting expression controlling thought
and regulating behavior
xi jinping has been cracking down on
everything from finance to entertainment
to whip his country through a national
rejuvenation
america china's nationalism is
explicitly anchored in maoism with mr xi
representing a new cult of personality
meanwhile woke america which consciously
or not deploys maoist tactics is
destroying the core traditions of
western civilization with identity
politics in both countries control must
extend to the very young to mold them in
the image of the official ideology
in fall 2020 chinese pupils returned to
school with a new requirement to study
xi jinping thought across the ocean
american pupils are taught that white
america is inherently racist regardless
of individual intention or action
chinese education pushes the young
indirections that serve the party in the
state
youths are trained to be skilled
laborers ready to endure hard work and
brutal competition american education is
supposed to be about opening minds but
appears not to fill them with much worse
young americans are not prepared for the
demands of being an adult it's much
worse than that american education right
now is geared toward teaching people
that the things that matter about you
are you your immutable racial
characteristics and your sexual
proclivities
and those sexual proclivities can span
the entire gamut of human existence
and this is the most important thing
about you who do you think is going to
win
really the only thing holding china back
from winning is the fact that they're
tied down to idiotic communism if they
were not they would be eating our lunch
much worse than they are right now
as a society when we abandon our own
central values when we abandon basic
truths about life reality comes to bite
you in the ass all right we'll get to
more in just one second first the daily
wire is searching for a highly motivated
client success manager to join our ad
revenue team in nashville tennessee we
care about our ad partners we want them
to enjoy success every time they
advertise with us in this position you'd
work hand-in-hand with our top partners
to launch and optimize the ad campaigns
so our clients can reach their goals
it's a great opportunity for somebody
with a customer-focused attitude who
wants to roll up their sleeves get their
hands dirty in various aspects of the
audio and digital advertising space five
plus years previous professional
experience in audio and digital
advertising with experience in podcast
advertising or copywriting is ideal for
this opportunity to apply to view a full
list of our current openings at
dailywear we have a bunch of them visit
dailywire.com
careers also if you have not heard you
must be living under a rock because the
daily wire shop is live it's ready for
all your extremely important christmas
and hanukkah needs yes you heard that
right daily wire merch is here head on
over to dailywire.com shop check out all
of the brilliant collections like the
chefouche design tees or let's go brand
and tailgate gear and so so much more
anyone can shop at the dailywear store
only daily ware members will get special
discounts up to 20 off
members also received access to shop
exclusive merch we've got our extremely
special baseball bat for example that's
handcrafted in collaboration with
pillbox bat company in celebration of
the good old days when cracker jacks
national anthem and take me out to the
ball game we're the norm in every ball
game members can now also purchase the
iconic leftist years tumbler that's
never before been available to buy
separately
so head on over to dailywire.com
shop to get a little something for
everyone on your list who loves brandon
if you're not yet a member sign up right
now at dailywire.com subscribe enter
code dw35 you get 35 off your membership
all the perks you wouldn't otherwise
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
societies that have confidence in
themselves stand up for their
centralized values and for their heroes
well meanwhile societies like the united
states we removed thomas jefferson
statues according to the new york post
thomas jefferson is no longer in the
room where it happens art handlers
packed up an 884 pound statue of
jefferson in a wooden crate on monday
after a mayoral commission voted to
banish the likeness of the nation's
third president from city hall where it
resided for nearly two centuries because
he owned slaves about a dozen workers
with martial fine arts spent several
hours carefully removing the painted
plaster monument from its pedestal
inside the city council chambers and
surrounding it with sections of foam and
wooden boards they then lowered that
massive structure down the stairs
leading to the building's first floor
rotunda with the pulley system ushered
the founding father out the back door
it's going to be on long-term loans in
the new york historical society which
plans to have jefferson's model survive
in its lobby and reading room
kerry butler executive director of the
public design commission that voted to
banish the statue at first tried to
block the press from witnessing the
removal butler relented after members of
the mayor's office and city council
intervened so there are now pictures of
a thomas jefferson statute being removed
very important to get rid of the guy who
wrote the declaration of independence
because history is filled with people
doing bad things and so we have to make
sure that's gone we need a george floyd
statue in there because truly what
signifies america is the victimization
of black americans not the
great and good founding principles that
allowed for the end of slavery in the
united states the end of jim crow in the
united states and the vast thriving of
vast numbers of black americans in the
united states particularly in the
post-civil rights era
okay this is
all of that is irrelevant the the really
relevant thing is that human beings
suffer in the united states because we
are a system that has decided that we
are bad and we are very very bad
meanwhile the teddy roosevelt statue at
the museum of natural history is going
to be moved to north dakota
the teddy roosevelt presidential library
foundation set to open in 2026 it said
in a statement it had entered into an
agreement with the city of new york for
the long-term loan and reconsideration
of the equestrian statute design by
james earl fraser this is according to
the new york post that announcement came
five months after the new york city
public design commission voted
unanimously to relocate the bronze
effigy of the nation's 26th president
amid claims it symbolizes colonial
subjugation and racial discrimination
it was vandalized with paint in 2017.
well the the idea i love this the
library agreed the statue is problematic
in its composition moreover its current
location eyes passerby's consent and
context
yes
if you are faced with the reality of a
statue you have not given your consent
to be faced with the reality of the
statute by the way that naked man peeing
on the street in new york city you
didn't give that your consent for for
that either but that's freedom freedom
is a man peeing on the street or
prostitutes walking the lanes and you
living in that side that's true freedom
that's that's the true blessing of
liberty right there but if you have to
walk by a statue of teddy roosevelt you
did not give your consent for that for
you to walk by that inanimate object
that's not bothering you in any way that
one you didn't give your consent to we
don't need your consent for the homeless
man crapping on the sidewalk to to do
that in front of your children
this is the society that we are creating
for ourselves
and this is this is what happens when
what you value is is your own sense of
self
pity over the realities of the world
history is filled with bad things
history is also filled with institutions
built before you or about
and and the belief that the world began
spinning when you are here and thus you
are the great moral arbiter of the
universe and get to reshape the universe
in line with all of your thinking is
destroying the country it's from
everything from history to race to sex
in the united states
and it's really really ugly
if if we wish to survive against the
forces of nature that exist outside of
us we're going to have to come to terms
with the fact that reality does exist
biological reality exists historical
reality exists the reality that your
singular choices in life make a very
large scale difference in how your life
turns out that's a reality that exists
and if we just decide that we're going
to blind ourselves to that reality well
we can wander around blindly until we
stumble directly into the fire of
reality and it is going to burn it's
going to burn an awful awful lot
speaking of the fire of reality so this
situation in waukesha wisconsin
continues to to
percolate
we still do not know why the the person
the the 39 year old black male who
decided to drive a a car into a crowd of
children why he did that we don't know
and we probably will never find out
because we are not allowed to ask such
questions because to ask such questions
might reveal that certain ideologies are
are not in fact good
according to the us son the suspect in
the christmas parade rampage that killed
five revelers wrote an anti-donald trump
rap and declared f the pigs according to
songs posted online
one of his songs includes the lyrics
they're going to need a cleaner for the
bleep we did all my killers at gacy
where their bodies hid here's a little
bit of his uh of his brilliant rap
this that malcolm x revolutionary
[Music]
so um both untalented incoherents and
has a terrible philosophy well we're not
supposed to investigate any of that
though if andy no posts anything about
his philosophy the journalists among us
what will shield us from the from the
vicious reality that maybe this guy
believed a lot of really bad stuff
by the way you know that if there's been
a white guy who drove a car into a crowd
filled with children and they had found
on his facebook page a bunch of white
supremacist garbage that would
immediately be the leading
motive that was suspected we know this
for a fact
so again blinding ourselves to reality
okay so this brings us to the most
obvious issue with what is happening in
in waukesha so one thing that we clearly
know at this point that this person
should have been in prison there's no
question that this guy should have been
in jail at this point
we know that he was out on bail thousand
dollars bail
from apparently using his car to hit
somebody like a few days before
and then he was just set free
joe biden finally reacted to waukesha by
the way uh it took him
like 48 hours to react to waukesha uh
suffice to say that if the races had
been reversed it would have to take him
less than a second and a half right if
you're a black guy if he'd been a white
guy driving a car into a crowd of
blackheads
biden would have been to the microphone
before the car has stopped moving um but
this was a black guy using a car to hit
a bunch of white kids and so apparently
that is um that's a different thing you
got you got it you can be considered
about it by the way should be considered
in both situations here is here's uh joe
biden finally sounding off about
waukesha
we know this morning
that five
families in waukesha
are facing fresh grief
of a life without a loved one
at least 40 americans are suffering from
injuries some of them in critical
condition
and an entire community is struggling
struggling to cope with the horrific act
of violence
last night the people of waukesha
were gathered to celebrate the start of
a season of hope and togetherness and
thanksgiving
this morning
jill and i and the entire biden family
and i'm sure all of us pray
that that same spirit is going to
embrace and lift up all the victims of
this tragedy
okay so glad that joe biden could be
bothered to emerge and say these things
uh it is uh it is also true that we know
at least from a policy perspective why
this happened according to cbs 58 in
wisconsin the waukesha police department
is referring five counts of intentional
homicide for the man accused of ramming
his suv into the waukesha christmas
parade those charges carry possible life
sentences there's the possibility more
charges will be filed as the
investigation progressives
this was not the first time that this
suspect and again i don't use names for
people who do this sort of stuff because
i don't like people being glorified for
this i don't think they should become
famous because of this i think that they
should be thrown in jail to rot and then
forgotten because that's what they
deserve this is not the first time this
suspect allegedly ran someone over with
his car
just three weeks ago he ran over a woman
he had a child with
but at the time his bail was set at just
a thousand dollars he paid it and was
released
now the milwaukee county district
attorney's office is conducting an
internal review into why the bail was
set inappropriately low
justice janine giesky who is on the
wisconsin supreme court from 93 to 98
explain quote there are hundreds and
hundreds of cases in milwaukee county
even the backlog of full homicides is
tremendous at this point
judge justice gusky said the district
attorney's office recommends the bail
amount to a court commissioner before
it's approved by a judge
it's not unusual for a court
commissioner to be sending 30 40 50
cases of bail on a day
the bail amount is supposed to consider
a person's prior record character
whether they might flee whether they
might commit a crime while out on bail
but there are plenty of red flags
because um this guy had a bail jumping
felony he had second degree recklessly
endangering safety felonies
he paid the one thousand dollars bail he
was released november 11th 10 days
before the waukesha parade the da's
office now says in a statement quote the
bail recommendation in this case is not
consistent with the approach of the
milwaukee county district attorney's
office toward matters involving violent
crime nor was it consistent with the
risk assessment of the defendant prior
to the setting of bail well there's only
one problem it's very consistent with
the with the milwaukee county d.a john
chisholm's approach
yesterday we talked to length on the
show about the fact that chisholm was
made nationally famous for his approach
to lobel
he put out a statement saying quote the
state's bail recommendation in this case
was inappropriate inappropriately low
and they're conducting an internal
review yeah no no bleeper conducting an
internal review
insane means totally crazy okay but
again we are now going to obscure the
real fact here we're going to pretend
that it was an suv right the suv was the
problem it's funny how this works by the
way if it's white guy in suv runs down
blackheads it's white guy an suv runs
down blackheads if it is in fact a a
black guy in an suv running down white
kids then the suv is the problem
look at the way that the media report
these headlines right there there's a
headline today
from cnn breaking news quote five people
have died and more than 40 are injured
after an suv plowed through a holiday
parade in waukesha
well you know that's unfortunate when
the suvs just sort of run out of control
all by themselves this way meanwhile the
left continues to foment the exact same
garbage policy that led to this in the
first place
so alexander ocasio-cortez literally put
out a a
message to legislators today
asking for bail reform
she put out a tweet this is sent out
within 24 hours of waukesha quote today
we sent a letter with representative
carolyn maloney
chairman chairwoman of the committee on
oversight and reform and representative
jamie raskin two new york city's five
district attorneys requesting
information on excessive bail in the new
york city court system when prosecutors
seek excessive cash bail it results in
increased rates of incarceration
particularly for low-income defense well
we wouldn't want
we wouldn't want criminals in the
prisons we need them out on the streets
obviously
you know the level of blindness and
honestly self-confidence you have to
have to make a statement like this in
the immediate aftermath of waukesha
so this criminal is out on bail
inappropriately low bail
and like within 24 hours
she and the rest of the democratic party
apparently are releasing a statement
calling for low bail
condemning thousands of individuals to
languish in an environment plagued by
persistent overcrowding and mounting
violence as they weigh trial is not
acceptable and risks violating their
federal civil rights if these conditions
are not addressed federal intervention
may be necessary to protect detainees
from additional harm we have grave
concerns excessive bail amounts are
leading to unnecessary pre-trial
detention
oh do you
and by the way if you think these people
are in any way tethered to reality they
are not
perhaps the the funniest clip of the day
jonathan swann of axios who is
basically like jon stewart now he just
interviews people and he asks them
really obvious questions and they have
no idea how to answer them i can't tell
you how many of these almost perottic
videos jonathan swann has put out at
this point where he asks someone a very
obvious and clear question and they have
no idea what to say about it so he was
interviewing the ex-girl rashida talib
one of the worst members of congress
she's just terrible vicious anti-semite
terrible person so he asked rashida
talib about her plans to basically
unleash criminals across the united
states
uh it goes poorly for a shooter to leave
to what extent have you wrestled with
any potential downsides of releasing
into society every single person who's
currently in a federal prison yeah
again i think that everyone's like oh my
god we're gonna just release everybody
that's not what i'm saying yeah but did
you see how many people are mentally ill
that are in prison right now no i know
but the act that you so
actually says release everyone but in 10
years but think about it who will
release it if there were like human
traffickers oh i know child sex so
do you mean that you don't actually
support that
and uh she's like
it's amazing so she she signed an act
right she she sponsored an act that says
release everyone and then he asks her
you mean everyone and she's like no not
everyone he's like so why did you sign
the act like well i mean everyone
okay politics is veep but it has very
serious consequences everybody thinks
politics is house of cards understand
something if you ever spend any time
with legislators the vast majority of
them have below room temperature iq
okay
our politicians are morons because most
of the people you know are morons and
politicians are no different
okay but what they do has vast national
ramifications
but if you just shield people from
reality and pretend that what they are
saying makes a lot of sense then you're
fine
you can pursue whatever delusional
policy you want without any sort of eye
on the ramifications
this is why dc has now recorded its
200th homicide of the year that's a mark
they haven't seen since 2004 according
to the washington post
homicides roads in 29 major u.s cities
through september compared with the same
period last year and they were up last
year too
killings across the country spent nearly
30 in 2020 according to the fbi
baltimore has now passed 300 murders for
the seventh consecutive year homicides
in philadelphia reached 496
on sunday
that's 14 higher than this time last
year
officials in the district and across the
country say there's no simple
explanation for the increase in deadly
violence district leaders have offered
many possible reasons including the
proliferation of illegal firearms their
use in seemingly minor disputes and
pandemic induced disruptions
um well it's i have an answer for you
it's really really easy not enough cops
too many criminals on the streets end
that's the whole thing done was that
super hard i feel like it was really
easy because i said it inside of 10
seconds
but we all have to pretend again shield
people from the realities of their own
bad policies that is the important thing
make sure that nobody has to face the
consequences of their own stupid notions
about how the world ought to work
the consequences are just borne by
everybody else right the consequences
are just born
by the most vulnerable and the weakest
and by the society at large again shield
yourself from reality but reality ain't
gonna shield itself from you reality is
coming for you one way or another
speaking of reality coming for you one
way or another uh joe biden apparently
wants to run for re-election yeah good
luck with that joe forget about running
for re-election the guy can't even
hobble for re-election so jen saki uh
she said yesterday that joe biden wants
to run for re-election which would be
the first time that an actual physically
brain-dead human being has run for
presidents of the united states you have
some people who are pretty close but but
uh i'm not sure that we've ever had a
person whose mind has uh has actually
turned to mush running for president of
the united states again that's exciting
stuff
there were reports that president biden
was telling allies that he is going to
run for re-election in 2024 can you
confirm is he going to run in 2024 is he
telling staff that yes that's his
intention
uh so that's good news by the way joe
biden says that he's gonna run in 2024
and he brags that he has a jobs
presidency and a small business
presidency let me remind you that right
now he's attempting to force every small
business with more than 100 employees in
the united states to vax their their
employees
that he wants all of these employees
apparently out of a job or to obey him
those are the only two possibilities
also he's created massive inflation
supply chain bottlenecks and he wants to
raise taxes corporate taxes on everyone
with an llc but don't worry this is a
jobs presidency and a small business
presidency says this delusional old man
america's small businesses are the
primary job creators innovators and
drivers that power our economic progress
that's why it's a powerful statement
about of the faith about that we have in
our country where our country and our
economy is heading
a small business creation is surging
surging in america today
which is why i'm proud to say
if you look at my presidency so far
it's a jobs presidency
and it's a small business presidency
no one believes this which is why he's
at 36 in the approval ratings also joe
biden is just lying about things he says
more people have more money in their
pockets even after inflation
statistically speaking this is not true
wages are actually down compared to
inflation now
things are getting better for american
workers
higher wages better benefits more
flexible schedules
balance sheets for american families are
better as well
savings are up
home equity is up
credit card balances are down
and if you continue and combine the wage
increases we've seen with the with the
direct relief my administration has
provided to middle class families the
typical middle class family's disposable
income has actually gone up two percent
this year even after accounting for
higher prices
um
is he kidding
okay real wages are down everyone knows
real wages are down
i mean even janet yellen is concerned
about it she says yeah we're on a strong
growth spurt at the moment they're just
going to try and talk their way through
this one here's janet yellen who is just
terrible at her job
if the fed acts quicker to taper pair
back its stimulus and acts quicker to
raise interest rates
does that risk a recession or choking
off the growth
well i see the us economy being on a
strong growth spurt at the moment
unemployment has been falling fast we
have seen
over 500 000 jobs a month since
president biden was elected and i think
that's going to continue into next year
driving down unemployment
so um
yeah good luck with that meanwhile nbc
news is saying maybe you should skip the
turkey inflation isn't real but that you
should skip the turkey says a
correspondent for the today show
while we are on the topic of something
that could be controversial
perhaps forego the turkey
bear with me i know that is the staple
of the thanksgiving meal however some
people think turkey is overrated and so
it tends to be the most expensive thing
on the table maybe you do an italian
feast instead and i will say this
if you tell everyone you're having a
thanksgiving without turkey
some guests may drop off the list and
that's a way to cut costs too
oh well it sounds great just lower your
expectations guys wear a sweater like
jimmy carter
lower your expectations here's the nice
thing okay so there's some people out
there who um who you know try to fight
reality i root for it i root for reality
because in the end reality wins anyway
and we can either adapt ourselves to
reality with systems that make sense
and the notion of natural law where we
adapt
how we behave to the realities of both
what humanity is and to how the world
works that is a better system reality is
going to win in the end that is the
comforting thought i always have i get a
lot of questions from people
about the future of the country the
future of civilization you know are you
pessimistic or optimistic well always in
the short term i'm pessimistic and
always in the long term optimistic
because here's the thing either we learn
or we get clocked we might get clocked
first but we are going to learn alrighty
we'll be back here later today with an
additional hour of content in the
meantime go check out the michael moles
show that's available right now i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro
[Music]
show the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliott feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pavel
wydowsky associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam scie events
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica crans the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
criminal justice reform leaves five
people dead and 48 injured in wisconsin
the gop peddles a radical transgender
bill and mostly peaceful looters empty
out three stores in san francisco check
it out on the michael knowles show
[Music]